this Calvin just woke up I just well
Callen just woke up we have special
guests in the house the man the myth the
legend
Andrew Schultz 8 thanks for coming in
man thanks he's been saying good things
about you I'll take it I've heard good
things about yeah I think everyone does
last night around the water cooler at
the Comedy Store
we were talking about you as a comic and
someone said top 5 right now okay I
haven't seen your [ __ ] stand up yeah
no got a watch man got a lot rate I love
to see I say I I'm so ignorant with this
done this then the door guys my guys
Derek they go dude he's like he's like
the describe more Trent we're talking to
Rogen about it he's like a bill burr but
younger wherever bill burrs line is he
[ __ ] goes past
oh boy yeah oh man I excited I've been a
fan for a while and then you do you have
so many how many shows do you have
because people give me [ __ ] but you got
a lot of [ __ ] go got to do it yeah
that's what I like I like your like your
model man so I do brilliant idiots with
Charlemagne and then I do flagrant too
and that's with my buddy Aakash
hilarious comic and Cass and then we
have a patreon app for that as well and
then then I do a few other shows on my
YouTube I kind of made like YouTube my
comedy Network so I have this like you
want to do TV do you want to do like a
regular Network show no I don't care
about that yeah I used to think that I
was supposed to do that you know I mean
and Congrats but no no no yeah no no
listen I would have told you it's for
sellouts but congrats but you're a
thespian like yeah I mean I went to act
yeah yes [ __ ]
plus you've been in tons of TV show yes
thank you but it's different it's like
later friend I'm like like dove you know
like dove David up like okay yes I was
like he's an actor does a [ __ ] four
not he's a really good actor like I just
knew dove as the stand-up great con and
then I see him acting it's like okay so
they're guys who truly love to do it I
think I was doing the acting stuff like
I did some show as I just said , I did
like a drama you know that kind of stuff
and like I think I was doing it because
that's what I was told I was supposed to
do as a comic yeah it's like oh you're a
comic then you get your sitcom and then
you do this and all I really wanted to
do was have a fan base and then perform
live yes that's why I wanted a special
and then when everybody said no when I
filmed my own special and everybody said
no and I and I put it out myself I
realize like I don't want a special I
just wanted to connect with fans see
that's how I feel that's right I think a
lot of us feel that way right so so
though so this special like when you
think about a Netflix special is what
you really want is people to see it so
you can play big crowd it says you can
write all you want you want people go oh
he's making money off your special real
name you can but the money that we make
money on the road that's what we do
that's an infomercial for it for you
exactly check it out man and it's like
so here's the question now right is like
is the special the best infomercial I
don't think it is meaning bit but I want
to talk to you and we could talk off air
about like yours and how you know we
could really get people to watch it but
also get the most out of it
you know I mean I think you have one
coming up - I saw an advertiser for
hours but it's like because I don't mean
interrupt because oh when I was
listening to brilliant idiots on the way
here I'm live here
and you and Charlamagne we're talking
about deuces marrow Jesus marrow tears
these American yeah yeah and they're on
Showtime then yes right yes and you go I
just hope it correlates because then
being on a network TV and being on that
the kind of brand their fan base is
digital yes like that that's Wanko
that's it old analog doesn't work it
doesn't really work yeah but it's um
it's on HBO no monster digital mom you
don't leave it mom leaving oh yeah in
the jump on HBO because people go look
here's all these views yeah let's bring
it here goes away it goes away it
doesn't nothing it was a like TVs now
everything's a screen and a TV is just a
shitty phone that's right dude that's
all that is is a horrible phone right it
doesn't call nobody right it doesn't
nobody all it does is the video watching
thing in your phone yeah right so like
if you put your whole special out on
YouTube I think it's gonna explode in a
way different way
than it would if you put it on Showtime
like if I'm Showtime this is a
conversation I have with you all fair
but maybe we [ __ ] have we have it on
there this is what I do the Showtime
I say Showtime give me the whole special
I'm gonna cut it up in the clips I'm
gonna put it on my YouTube and this is
just a branding thing to bring awareness
to me as Showtime talent yeah and now
you're gonna watch below the belt or all
these others I think because that's all
it that's what Showtime wants right like
I just want I ball gonna make no money
off this special right it's just they're
investing is you is talent on the
network and that's what I did like what
everybody said no too much my how long
does this is over a year ago this is a
year ago almost three years ago I filmed
it right
so I filmed the special I did like five
clubs in New York I did like the cab
rides in between an idealist tonight in
New York right yeah and I broke my hour
up into that just so you know in New
York what we used to do is we'd go from
like you go from Stan of New York comic
strip yeah you go to and you go to New
York Comedy Club on 24th Street then you
go down to Romano did it down the cellar
and Ramon would do that like and you can
actually pay your rent that way so you
actually make money so you shot you're
special like that so this is two years
ago right and literally what you
described is what how I did the hour and
I do like that because that's how I
built the hour like you know you people
listen did are comics no it's like a lot
of times you don't build this in our
time you build this ten minutes of time
five minutes a time at little spots so I
did I did the cameras in between it was
like boom here's the hour I try to shop
to everybody everybody says no lowest
point my comedy career now in there but
yeah and and it's like but the comedy
the stand-up world has never embraced me
for whatever reason it doesn't matter
how sold and it did just I've never done
the reason you never see my never done
stand-up on TV or any of these types of
things right but it's okay it was
prepared me for what I am today like I
needed to go through everything needs to
be stripped in order for me to to lead
right so it's like I put out this I
started asking my friends you can learn
so much about comedy from asking people
who are comics mm-hmm right and I was
like who you watching on Netflix right
and everybody would say you know the
names that we all know Mulaney Giulio
Chapelle and then I beg did you like it
yeah it was really good but I mean I
didn't finish it
everybody kept saying infinite everybody
everyone every so I'm like okay so
they're not watching the whole thing
boom instead of me putting out the hour
I'm gonna do a 15-minute version of this
right I put out the 15-minute version
that week and I saw some shows down in
San Diego and I wasn't a sellout guy
and you put it out on YouTube on you too
I'm on my own too [ __ ] right 50 members
best meal is one you can have one more
bite off right so I put out I saw some
shows woman [ __ ] is going on is weird
alright I go you know what I'm gonna get
into this I'm gonna like start putting
out clips every week so I start putting
out a clip every single week for a year
that's just real because I had another
30 minutes left or 45 minutes left of
that special and then I had other jokes
that I didn't put in it but there was
like material that I had to like throw
away because I was willing throw it away
anyway and I had the new hour because I
was touring with that I put it out and
all of a sudden the clips start to go
viral like I start to sell on how it
shows and I go on these tours and
usually get bigger at to an
international tour that I sell I like
things things start getting crazy oh
also in the moment I realized what I
cared right I didn't care about getting
the special yeah as much as I cared
about being able to touch the people
there's nothing like it because that
special is the validation right I think
it's when you walk around other comics
ago you especially I picked up me go HBO
Showtime no seriously though kind of
steuby yeah used to be because what what
used to happen is we could we correlate
that special with selling out tickets
right but now we have friends of ours
that we all know that have our specials
on Comedy Central and that are doing
$1500 weekend's in major markets they
can't sell it's true what the reason I'm
I sell so well now is because of this
Paulo Tennessee and no one can find my
[ __ ] like so I'm gonna take my old
special which has been sitting you know
in Neverland yeah and put it on YouTube
this new one that's coming out at least
it'll be on every platform put it on
YouTube the full thing and that's not
going to talk to you about take pieces
right so what I did is I did a new piece
every single week and this is what
happens
I made it suggestible if I said hey you
wanna listen this guy talk for an hour
you tell me [ __ ] myself
I don't listen nobody talk for now
that's right right so a stranger seeing
you and going I want to listen to this
guy for an hour is absurd it's just
absurd 2019 especially now with all the
great love some of these comics and I
find myself after 20 you can't do 30
minute
I'm so fascinated by this conversation
though because it gets crazier this is
this is changing for me as a dude just
windy right gallon he gets crazy and
it's the right time for all of us to
have it be to both have can let's go get
your cash make my gray cash you know
what Brian I'm gonna stop charging you
the twenty percent royalty for your
career that's what I'm gonna do for you
you guys are both hip to you guys
there's something hip about the way
you're dressed but you're young huh
you're young this is good it's supposed
to be that way I'm also I'm over the old
swollen face sorry
don't need a wheel you know what you
need us you need to swell up a little
bit when you get older because I don't
like it when when it's too bony yeah
you're right Madonna has that like weird
you're right I need I know this is still
tight as [ __ ] though is that or is that
weird I can't tell ya but you will later
I can't my shirt a beach and I'm saying
yeah you need to stretch but you I mean
I called up ready the [ __ ] you talking
about hey bro school him school the
guest school a a s keep going cuz I love
this so we put it out right and I just
put out these a little pit these little
bits and I started to notice this thing
that happen somebody my YouTube guy
would hit me and he bag a man there's
some cool happen I'm like what's up and
he'd be like people watch one video and
then they watch for two hours right hmm
and I'm like what he goes yeah they get
like in a wormhole and they just keep
watching I don't really
so Netflix can't get someone to watch
from 1 to 20 minutes we got people
watching for two hours Benjen right
there binging because it's right in
front of them is right there and it's
it's got it you got to have the goods
obviously but it's right there it's
right in front of them it's always
accessible right and it's not this thing
where when you sit down watch an
hour-long Netflix thing you're like I
need to be here for an hour you don't
for me you need to be there for three
minutes yeah and then when that bits
over like it's over
and you can come back another time like
I could save Netflix home they're just
idiots that run Netflix comedy like
they're [ __ ] incompetent like I could
save that whole [ __ ] model with two
technological changes really the whole
thing that they haven't done yet I say
it
received you do yeah I almost don't want
to give it to him until I think
Whitney's doing hers for Netflix and I
think I'm gonna give it to Whitney so
that she can be the bee that like be the
person that gets to but I mean well
you're saying about this about and he's
been saying this to is that we are
living in a time when and I do this all
time you you have 15 minute chunks
do you have five minutes you know and
that's what we do it I'm on YouTube all
the [ __ ] all the time oh you know how
do i watch you guys YouTube yeah I'll
watch the chunks yeah you know I mean
I'll watch these Huddle's yeah I've
watched it a little highlight or like a
12-minute conversations right this is
gonna sound even even weirder than
you'll laugh at it but like I love to
box I like I like to work at it I'm not
I'm never gonna be but I learn more
sometimes watching five-minute clips on
YouTube of some really high level coach
who teach you a little something
and so I we're all if I have a sync
issue I go on like everything is when
but comedy especially if I want to get
entertained but with comedy to like it
let's say you don't know who Andrew is
and you watch a clip I'm the guy if I
see something for three minutes it kills
I hope I'm in wait he's coming where
he'll be in LA I changed my it's like if
not only our sales okay babysitter I'm
paying for hey I'm gonna spend $100 100
all night yeah and I throw a lot of
money for most people yes so that's 100
bucks or let's call it 75 80 bucks
that's like holy [ __ ] man I better no
and I don't have time I'm what will get
the kids the vets over there and then
put it on me help it the movies have
been doing it though the movies give you
that little snip preview yours damn
that's all right that's what when's it
come out I'm buying a ticket for the
normal thing that's exactly right but
that's the thing like and if there's any
comics ilysm right now it's like if you
don't have clips up on youtube right now
you're [ __ ] because nobody's going
out to your show that weekend without
seeing what you're like first well I've
had to build it on the road slowly
because I wasn't it so my first special
Showtime
yes that's locked up I don't even know
where it is I have to talk to the people
that own it I can't
I can even released he gets flagged so
now I might that's that lease on
Instagram release on Instagram okay
until there's all right doesn't matter
where it is that's another thing like
put that out but also I was from 1917 oh
but Saul knows that but so is it there's
some really
that's a coffin axes lieutenant he was
he was doing stand-up in 1719 I just
came down from from Boston don't do that
trip took me 14 days but yeah man so I'm
but I think you've got me thinking you
got you got to put it out here's the
question yeah I have zero material on
youtube you need a different road but
here's everything like I wonder at times
like so so now I'm working on my new
special mind that my one hits Martin at
12th I'm doing press like I'm doing the
craziest amount of press but you can get
it on all the platforms yeah all right
fine but we also press now for it no not
yet okay you only do press one saying
yeah yeah in fact they tried to and I
was like hold no waste of time people
forget correct
so and again maybe they forget so do it
right away where they can go to they can
go rent and buy it but yeah I agree with
you that it did for me the biggest thing
is I want people come I want to sell out
theaters I want I don't give a [ __ ] I
just want a lot of people to come see
because I love performing that's what I
live for all numbers give them a
[ __ ] away give it away
Costco give it away off we should hit
this a bi there what does Costco do well
I had this conversation with this
[ __ ] I wouldn't trust you you
should have had him on earlier way to go
there goes my I gotta wait another two
years no you don't just keep because it
benefits everybody involved to give it
away I think the I could go to whatever
so many we good this pot yeah that's
away
look Fame is all about intimacy now it
used to be about distance yeah right
yeah like and who gets it better than
Will Smith hmm Will Smith bombs for
movies in a row but he's so [ __ ]
smart he goes what the [ __ ] is happening
I'm Will Smith yeah
whatever I do wins and this is not
winning what's going on and he realizes
oh [ __ ] fame is not about hiding out in
the hills and then coming out and do a
movie to two times here one time of year
Fame now is about hey how you doing hey
I'm here hey this is my family hey this
is everything that's going on we do
I'm normal wouldn't like you guys
whatever one of your fans say when they
meet you right they know you and they do
what was what was Fame ten years ago for
fifteen years twenty years ago he goes
no nothing they're not exact read why is
Johnny Depp a bozo curious
he's oldest bo wait why does he has no
friends you didn't come down to the real
work phone go what the [ __ ] are you
doing I what do you have so many
necklaces you have a friend who can tell
him hey bro
enough with the [ __ ] look at that to go
to the top left one and you could see
the full front row of Bryan Callen oh
dude he's just he's just he's out and
like he's not he's not one of us he's
not a human he's from another planet he
just has no idea what's up month and
when someone goes dude you're so many
movies are terrible no one's told him
that I now he thinks he's Jack Sparrow
he really does he does he said don't
worry wearing eyeliner he's kind of
awesome but what I think is interesting
too back to Will Smith is he went okay
I'm doing these movies they are bombing
I need to get down to put my ear to the
ground and he goes so instagrams what
everyone's all about oh cool you want to
see what talent looks like an Instagram
boom so will takes literally is pay game
over here and again to this page and you
go oh [ __ ] three months youtubers and
Instagram novels or do try and come to
creative [ __ ] and then a real guy with
real talent goes I'm gonna put some
resources in this put my creative brain
behind it and his page is like no he's
the best YouTube Instagram all that [ __ ]
best by far but he just recognized the
shift and a lot of people don't
recognize the shift the networks don't
recognize the shift but they don't want
to recognize it because but it just
gives this gives the odd artist for the
first time ever a world economy where
we're in control each control this is it
like I did the amount of unity he was
with me I was fretting I work on the
special is the best thing I've ever done
online
who's Netflix won't watch it you know
Showtime pastime like
same-same [ __ ] I'm like how the [ __ ] 30
I know what I do I know what I do to
audiences I do know I'm not to be but
that's the only thing I'm lucky or [ __ ]
boy right bomb last night because no it
was it but you know I was like how is
this not you know and and again [ __ ] you
don't need no I don't need them no one
needs its you control your own desert
taking clips and just it's old model and
we make our money when we do theaters
that's the thing they like if you're not
a stand-up or you're not someone who
could do the live show now is a scary
time if you're just a producer you got
to be [ __ ] your pants right yeah
because you can't produce a show and
then tour it you got to get paid for
that show you produce know like yeah the
way I look at the comedy game is like
we're just 10 years behind music I'm the
first like SoundCloud comedian put it
that way right like yeah musicians start
giving their [ __ ] away and then they
make money on the road they sell out the
garden that's a million that's all they
care about if I [ __ ] about musics doing
it yeah and but the region road children
everybody so for you always it's like
what we do anybody who leads right like
you gotta take power power has to be
taken you can't no one gives you power
you have to [ __ ] grab it out of
somebody's rush in this right in
anything in life right and the but the
thing about taking powers that's the
last thing you take right because once
you're in power all you do is give right
these are your people you protect your
people hey somebody's trying to go to
war with y'all you're the first one on a
horse like all right let's go [ __ ] those
twos up and it's like you you have to be
prepared to handle that kind of power
not everybody is right like you have
some scumbag kind of leaders the spoiled
Prince the son of the king who took
power as a cop he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
cuz he never had to take it yeah he's
trying to validate himself so that's
what we were we're trying to validate
ourselves with these professional career
right it's like hey this is a good
that's my dignity
I'm older yes and so this this model in
a Hollywood model forever has been I did
I just want to smack you saying I'm
older and different different episodes
not because you going will show that my
entire career had let's just take the
last 17 years but really the past 23
when you're an actor and how you come to
Hollywood you are this person who went
to theater school there were channels so
you go to theater school you spend like
you know and then you of course get into
an acting class because you see you you
have to win that audition and there's
there are there are suits they were
suits and they were smart dresses and
back then it was mostly men and you you
would walk into a room with these men
and it was all about and you'd wait
another you'd wait in a waiting room
with your [ __ ] sides and you'd wait
there and you'd be working and by the
way you needed this job because you knew
that there was a pilot season there was
a small window where the L the [ __ ]
networks they would buy your pilot and
then they would greenlight your pilot
and oh my god and then they would cast
it and now whoever they were I you would
have this they you didn't know who they
were but you'd come into that room and
there'd be there and they would never
they'd just be like how are you and they
were all there were sitting down yeah
and you do you're still going on still
going on but it was everything back then
because because if you got a sitcom if
you got um there was no stand-up was
nobody was making money on stand-up you
have to understand nobody but industry
doesn't make money on us nobody back
then nobody was making do nobody had we
didn't have stand-up really we would you
did stand-up you did like Rogen would do
um like there were clubs that were set
up but you would never making real money
you just weren't some people very few
people we weren't but more importantly
the industry wasn't and that's why they
didn't invest in it yeah the joke is an
avocado yeah right it's like yeah it's
[ __ ] the second you cut that [ __ ] open
that's right it's you're done you're
done
there's no sheltered life and so all of
it but everybody every performer whether
you're an actor you you had to you were
at the lowest man on the totem pole no
matter what you just had no power no
matter what you just was up to you and
sometimes somebody would sneak through
on a show they'd get popular and then
you had power yeah for a while until
that show went away and then it start
all over again and it seems like now
let's flare the first time it's all
flipped cuz it used to be a buyers
market now it's a seller's now it's the
sounds we own the creativity [ __ ] yeah
we that's the other week when we had all
these offers Fox everybody wanted to
kind of buy it or they own it yeah and
he was like no let's just do it
ourselves
you know you have to it's the only way
you know we're maintained then we left
Fox when they're like well we need 50% I
was like well we're out yeah yeah do you
know what we need is two mics that's
right why would we give you 50% I'm out
and there's still people in podcast
because yeah I'm thinking about signing
with this network you're caught in this
matrix right we're like we all get
caught in the matrix the success is
equivalent to money matrix and I think
the second you realize like how much joy
you get from doing what you do and
everything else is icing on the cake
yeah then you can pull yourself out of
it I was locked in it too that's why I
was so down from when everybody said no
because you but you also you come from
and I want to be curious if I'm sure
your fans know but you I mean you were
an MTV guy oh yeah network deals and
[ __ ] like that like I was at multiple
shows I did a right after MTV I was a
lena sitcom you know I got your back
what sitcom it was called benders I
loved you in that when you and
Charlamagne were talking about your guys
time on MTV the freaking talent that was
walking around greater than MTV oh your
mind really just everybody now came up
through there I mean I even said you
know is there P like if you if you even
want top up the business you know like
if you want to look at like the young
black comics like who will be the next
Kings of Comedy yeah like all those
dudes the Carlos Miller Chico beans like
the DC young flies like these guys came
up through wild now I'm gonna make DS
Amero who are on Showtime right now they
came up through MTV to like duval who's
been popping for a while Charlemagne and
myself even be on sodor like you want to
go to like monsters the New York
Charlemagne I don't know walking the
best smart guy so sharp and so honest
like I've seen him take Kanye to task
and yeah he's he's brilliant man and I
remember that one guy who came in and
was really mad at him that
rapper who was like you know oh yeah
birdman birdman yeah he's a he's like a
producer yeah yeah yeah but he's such a
he's such a house-call howdy how did you
guys meet at empty yeah we met at MTV
and it was just like I think before
Charlemagne was the guy at MTV I was the
guy there right like they would have me
hosting the Spring Breaks and hosting
the European Music Awards and [ __ ] like
so I bet you guys didn't [ __ ] any girls
[Laughter]
stupidly had a girl at that time it was
bad Charlamagne yeah he's had a wife for
like 18 years but he used to cheat yeah
I know now he's he's part of like the
faithful got more the few faith brags
about now being faithful T so during at
that time you're the man than
Charlemagne came in Charlemagne then
Charlotte comes in he is he like takes
over New York radio like what he did
with the with power 105 one is really
only like Stern did that back in the day
did he did he get a start with one day
we got I started Wendy yeah he did that
and he did stuff with Wendy and he had
been working in Philadelphia I think and
he just got fired from every place 41 40
41 what I think what works with with
both use especially for you as you guys
went through that TV route and if you
said the same stuff because I'll show
you guys show and seeing with Brian and
Brian might get fired but if some of the
stuff that we say so outlandish yeah if
you put that on MTV Showtime or in
network they like do we can't have it oh
yeah it's cost us a lot of money and
again we don't need it no you don't need
it but it's good because we have this
other thing and thank God because then
you're allowed to say it but like yeah
man I mean we've had things that cost us
you know I mean Nicki Minaj cost me
$100,000 how so because I said this she
had kind of a [ __ ] vibe
I remember this this you were the guy
who said it these days legit he knows
rap but then he said he's a white dude I
don't know
we only say it like I'm like I'm not an
authority remember this hundred grand
how did this hold out I just said I said
the reason why people are not for me
brilliant it's something I was like the
reason why people are into cardi B and
not Nicki Minaj is because cardi is
giving us an authentic version of
herself she has characters yeah and the
characters work when there wasn't like
anytime you put a real Jordan next to a
fake one how fake does the fake Jordan
look like even on stage like when
someone's giving you the real and then
like a young guy gets up and he's trying
to do a version of himself it just feel
like you know my mother always said my
mother always said we were communicating
with each other well long before we
developed language yes so human beings
can tell when you're lying
yeah you-you-you know right away and
especially when you perform especially
when you're trying to be when you're
trying to pull one over on an audience
there's another saying that Robert McKee
in his book screenplay said the
audience's IQs jumped 20 percent when
they are watching a movie why we've been
watching movies since we were little
kids so you cannot just kill anybody
with with tricks and how good yeah it's
a very very [ __ ] truth if you don't
respect your audience and if you don't
actually and I've always said this if
you don't believe that your audience is
as smart as you are then you're in big
[ __ ] trouble yeah it comes out of
respect yeah absolutely that so I just
you said that I said she's got kind of
[ __ ] vibe right and I do she's a line
her opening lines one of her song is I'm
a [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] but this is no we
agree that's known throughout the
industry that she's like super difficult
to work at everyone she's getting
everything she deserved right now
because it's falling apart yeah [ __ ] to
cancel our tour to the ticket but that's
on you it's like what you put out in the
ecosystem is what comes back and I know
that sounds like some like foo-foo
[ __ ] put on some real it's like if
you put good vibes out like Brendan puts
so many good vibes out to me this week
so I want to give vibes to you it's just
a natural organic thing and like you
even look at like like Rogen like Rogen
seemingly put good vibes out in the
world also these things that are coming
back to him or deserved you know people
rise to the top it's just and that's
what I was saying about like the
leadership thing it's like so the people
who are built to lead
don't want right there in a position
where they're filled emotionally so
they're ready to give herself a lot of
us have been in that position where
we're not filled emotionally so like we
can't even compliment our friend who we
think is funny yeah it's hard for us to
go hey Brian that set was so [ __ ]
funny like it made me feel insecure
watching you set it's hard it makes you
vulnerable it makes you vulnerable cuz
deep down you like dizzy funnier than me
what does that mean but when I am right
after you kill yeah and we're feeling
full yeah how much you want to just
complement your boys in so gratitude to
the homies like anyway so it was just
one of those things where I'm Dale
pulled out there like we want to
apologize for what you said we're gonna
pull out this advertiser now as I [ __ ]
you are you can't you can't cuz it would
ruin what you stand for
exactly you can't a pop for as well you
never apologized publicly cuz all that
does is confirm what people think you
said like there's a lot of women right
now that think Louie like held down
women jerked off on their face they
truly believe that yeah right and he
didn't and he didn't but since he
apologized he confirmed the worst their
belief the worst right yeah you never
apologized
if there's one thing you learn from
Trump do not apologize bubble keep going
keep it moving
[ __ ] growing him right now he's in
Vietnam like y'all this food is
delicious yeah what the ultimate
dictator crazy right but that's what you
learn is like [ __ ] that apology [ __ ]
keep going everybody's gonna be offended
by something yeah like if offended is
the is the line we can't go I love that
I love that saying I think Sam era said
a being offended is not a position nor
is it an argument of course not like
you're offended what and and what Jesus
is the Lord the Savior the heart is like
a lot of people offended by that yeah
the hardest thing that all I see is you
know this we're right now in a time
where people blow their horn and
therefore their side and they criticize
the other side awesome
what are you [ __ ] doing to change the
world are you actually persuading
anybody on the other side and and so it
doesn't matter and like you said I mean
I think you your audience is your
audience and they're gonna and now they
flip out like you always say it's like
when when you've got your ecosystem on
the web that's actually all that donors
you are the network you have to be
authentic to them but but Steve Simone
said this to see Simone right at the
combination yeah he's been there for
every the one of the best guys ever a
lot like probably two years ago maybe
three years ago he came up through Matt
hey man a lot of people are gonna hate
on you because you have a built-in
nodding so hey Donnie could you play to
your crowd egos you look around everyone
here wants their crowds yes that's what
they're doing this for yes do not change
me yeah do not change yes
it's like communist we're you should do
em you should like take your shirt off
and do UFC [ __ ] to up there
do you like fighting stuff now yeah no
I'm not gonna give you one out in just
UFC short that you're on UFC I did like
just wear one glad you're a big Jay
oakerson but with us yeah and if you
when I was ready job you see guys don't
even laugh just tap out
tell me when you guys tap when I'm too
funny guys ready to submit to my comedy
[Applause]
comedies are knockout yeah guys I'm a
real knockout artist that should be your
promo ah no that's um your promo no
should cut a promo sarcastically
addressing all that the time you are
away from it it's a new hobby no no it's
it's satire saying over like this you're
over the top this guy's gonna kiss you
just like to laugh joke in the laugh but
so nobody see so knowingly [ __ ] that
you're calling out what every so bad
everybody could say yeah it's like
that's actually rose then then the
8-mile approach it's literally a mild
right it's like I'm gonna say all the
things that you would say about me and
now it's Trump
what are you gonna say you guys thought
I was a great fighter boy wait'll I
knock you out with my comedy and queen
you know yeah that's it
real talk you got you had to get a
Joseph Gordon green and Danny McBride
variety like to put it together that's
hilarious
dude it would be so good and then you
call out what everybody that wants to
hate before they do it yeah because
that's all we do now right is we don't
like information we conference it's a
Prius how I feel tell me why cause I'm
gonna show the other day they don't
forget I was doing this show I was in
the green room with another comic and
the producers going through what we're
supposed to do and he goes he was
already what do you want me to what do
you want me to push in the others I just
got my special man no adult man Congrats
he goes yeah yeah 25 [ __ ] years man
took me 25 [ __ ] years and the guy's
never been nice to me yeah he's never
been nice to me the vibe was cool in
there too
yeah and he's never been friendly to me
and then the previously goes Oh Brendan
I knew that guy's listen he's never been
a fan of mine there's Brenda don't you
have a special come out here yeah
Showtime Angus damn how long you been
doing somewhat three weeks but like
that's why you can't be upset you can't
be like offended by you can like that
jealousy things never made doesn't make
sense because I have a special you think
it takes away from the otaku or you have
these people like them to do they just
don't understand business but like it's
famine thinking it's weird [ __ ] it's
it's it's like it's a smart decision to
invest in your product I was like why
does Amanda SEALs have a special on HBO
well what is she also owned on HBO
insecure correct yeah so brilliant it's
like I would if I'm a business I'm going
to invest in the talent but it's also
like this like I always say about
Brendon like you know we were talking
privately about this and I was like um I
think you had told me that story and I
was like oh okay I know I know
and because it was so easy to get here
and get your audience it was so easy
dude all you have to do is this ready no
it's so easy ten thousand just has what
you do is what you want to do is just
get in the UFC and fight heavyweight
yeah if I can fight the monsters in your
underwear but you know and but go
through the training and throw up when
you have concussions when you're
sparring partners Shane
Carwin saying that all I'm saying is
that that should have been in Grambling
but but no of course what I'm saying
though is that you built an audience
that was your first audience he was a
social media beast when he was doing
that and then you [ __ ] decide I'm I
guess I'll do a podcast you do that for
a long time you build an audience with
that now you're combining the audience
and then you go I'm think I'm gonna do
stand-up and I was like why yeah
everybody was like these people have an
antiquated view of like the
entertainment business that we're in
right now and it's just like but it took
an accident of course not everybody's
gonna have their there person right like
you could say like let's say for example
Charlemagne is my guy just as many
people who are like you know the only
reason you've got this because you're in
the UFC just many people say you know
the only reason you got this because
you're Charlemagne everybody's gonna
have that what do you do with it what
are you doing with your yeah exactly
because there's everybody everybody is
gonna have someone if you're decent if
you're not if you're not even decent
you're not gonna get that and that's why
you suck yeah but if you just have you
gonna have an opener I mean [ __ ] D'Elia
was opening for COI Yeah right like
everybody's gonna have em kelan hey
Carolyn right let's just be just be
undeniable there's good tons of people
creating listen a lot of guys I'm sure
open for Rogan that aren't doing stuff a
lot of guys open for the big guys that
aren't doing stuff it's like you're
gonna get that opportunity and it's not
necessarily Network it could we're
networks now yep we have eyeballs what
are you gonna do with that how are you
are you to come in with ideas do I have
to do it for you or you gonna come up to
me with ideas every single week my
channel the [ __ ] YouTube fan pieces
Instagram Twitter is it keep doing keep
shooting our material and then no one
sees what's your [ __ ] hand down what
was your last one see so hey there I'm
in business other places that's where my
dramedy that did was for see so and then
it folded so is on Hulu see so I grabbed
a bunch of content for a hot SEC yeah
and then just was like you know a
horrible idea the good news they're all
good all those other two hours put them
on YouTube you put them on Instagram
it's just you just put them out I mean
the thing is that the business is
crumbling like everything's falling
apart everything literally the whole
structure of Hollywood have fallen
Netflix has done no people don't even
realize Netflix is that it's it's like I
heard that they the guy said
from the other Network effects he was
like well if you believe that those 700
shows are doing well like all of them I
can believe in the easiest question yeah
if you had a show on your network that
you owned that was doing well would you
pay a hundred million dollars for a year
of friends the only shows people watch
on Netflix
it's a nostalgia viewing yeah it's
friends in the office women watch
friends do watch the office that's all
people watch they make a movie here's
the thing with Netflix right there
they're not even trying to make money
now Netflix is trying to be they're
trying to be bought out they're naughty
they don't even they're ten billion in
debt they're not even trying this is the
thing about Netflix right and this why
you guys are already on it you guys are
already on top of it you may not even
realize it but you're on top it's like
YouTube is waiting there just waiting
for Netflix to be like you know that
scene in the movie where the water is
coming up and you just you have your
lips right up here they're just gonna
pour one little drop of water and it's
around them that's this is what YouTube
is doing they're just waiting with their
thumbs and they don't even have
important lots of water so what did you
rob gonna do that they all have to do
anything right so this is how it works
you see Charlie Wilson's War yes okay
so remember what we did in Afghanistan
where it was like we armed the Afghans
who are fighting the Russians we give
them $5,000 rocket launchers and they
shoot down 5 million-dollar helicopters
right netflix pays aaron sorkin
a hundred million dollars to make a TV
show that distracts you for two hours
YouTube pays Brendan and Brian zero
million dollars to make a podcast that
distracts you for two hours
mm-hmm you're dead yeah you can't win
you cannot win it is impossible for you
to win you have one chance at winning
Netflix and that's if you get the rights
to all sports if you don't get the
rights to all sports and they're not
coming that's not because you can't
afford it you lose and they will lose so
what they'll do is they'll get bought
out by Apple because there's a my
friends a mathematician said that
Netflix makes money on subscription yeah
you run a drop mistake you run out of
subscription models like like there's no
people the price already right
right up in the price and we don't mind
about the price it's if they don't have
that nostalgia viewing if they don't
have the thing that we can go watch and
just keep on watching the same thing
then I'll have one of these shows yet if
they don't have it right we're not gonna
it also doesn't matter who's watching
what though because they make their
money on that subscription because you
want people to keep renewing their
subscription Yeah right so do he's not
go to Netflix as I can watch Planet
Earth or I can watch those things but I
do have to say as I scroll through there
were so many things on that for you too
yeah somebody has ripped off dude
YouTube is the sleeping giant and I'm
telling you when it wakes up it's gonna
but then whatever off that means
everything is free or how does that work
everything's free
everything's free everything's falling
apart like everybody so then then what
happens to content so who's gonna
finance whatever you ready no no no no
this is what happens the content right
yeah it's a creators market because the
three of us can sit here and we can make
two hours worth of engaging content yeah
for a hundred bucks
yeah okay I can engage you I can have
ideas for days I can see I can meet you
and be with you for ten minutes and I
can find five different programs that
you should do I just didn't have the
bandwidth yet then I got the bandwidth
and I was like okay let me just start
creating all my own [ __ ] i buy the
cameras cameras used to be the barrier
of entry kami used to be a hundred
thousand dollars what do we record on
this that's five hundred hours yeah
doing it it's like these hundred bucks
yeah Mike's a few hundred it's nothing
the Baron entry isn't there yeah and I
can upload it at a place where which has
the most eyeballs in the world it's over
for you available to everybody
avail I mean the only like this is how
the networks are so [ __ ] stupid like
if I was then what I would do is
everything would be a nostalgic
programming from now on like remember
when the oj thing came on yeah the OJ
trial and effects hell yeah it's like or
like a Bobby Brown story you just gotta
tap in the ship from our childhood those
markets yeah exactly because that's the
only reason we watch we're not watching
your stupid show like God friended me
yeah like what about life's what about
like does own and those these new apps
it's interesting to zone I yeah what do
you think about that do zones different
because do zone has the Asia market so
in Asia they're huge so I just had all
those guys on my show yesterday the one
championship guys I don't why you know
why would you sign and this is me
by Justin do my research well enough
when I looked into it but to Zone in
Asia where if they put on a card one
championship does they get more eyeballs
way more on that one card than UFC does
not even close they'll get 20 million
views Wow they love fighting over the
sodas Oh makes their money off of that
they're huge in China Tokyo Joe you guys
are making money excuse me I love it how
do you think they paid [ __ ] canal 365
million dollars
yeah they have so much money so they
went oh my we've conquered Japan and
Asia we got all that let's head over
this way let's head over well okay I
don't know over here they sign Anthony
Joshua they got Canelo snap too you know
I mean they got it and they have things
that sports get sport blue to your point
with Netflix to save their ass they
would have to give it and they can be a
NFL which is MLB that's not hot guess
you'll have sports hey youtube I can get
YouTube TV for 40 bucks and I can get
all my sports and all this more TV
YouTube TV is just cable on your YouTube
and they run the ads during the ABC or
Fox promotion like you'll see a YouTube
like watch YouTube TV like it's just
it's again it's over Frank everyone to
tube TV yeah it's a greatest thing cuz
you have it on your phone and successful
I just want to be in every store
somebody hearing about you I'm [ __ ]
Oh check it YouTube used to have like a
premium function YouTube bread and there
was YouTube their pay they're like
paywall because they were dabbling it's
like should we do pay well should we not
they just took that away because do
bread yeah now they're just gonna be
buying content only have to do is
calling her and sort can be like hey
what is a Netflix giving you other give
me 100 all right we'll give you 110 you
got come over here it's that easy
dude like people don't even realize
India just got phones yeah man
they don't have cameras correct like
there's so few Indians walking around
with a [ __ ] red cam or like a DSLR
but they all got phones you could watch
it over a million people
you got 1.2 billion people that need to
watch it I was like why are my clips
going viral in India like I was trying
to put together the dots my boy goes oh
yeah they just got like Internet out
there like huge Indians Pingris speaking
personal they all speak English all
speak English
they just got they educated they love
stand up stand up six Plotinus
everywhere like weird you know
we're the new hip-hop yeah we're the new
hip-hop I understand like the world and
this is these [ __ ] idiots don't
realize they're like okami doesn't
travel go around the world ask people
how they learn English
Family Guy Simpsons career yeah that's
how they learned it where that is this
is the new hip-hop and this is why it is
because it's the only place you could
talk [ __ ] like in their countries you
can't go on TV and talk [ __ ] I was in
Malaysia you couldn't talk about the
dictator no there's one place when we
were doing stand-up on stage yeah
and I'm watching chicks and hit jobs
dying laughing no dying laughing about
jokes [ __ ] about damn about the dictator
whatever it's like whoa commies
important where were you a Kuala Lumpur
Malaysia yeah yeah and all I'm saying is
they all speak English enough enough
it's getting there it's getting there
enough we're like dude I'm telling you
this is our Lobel thing Facebook is
getting into it too though they're
looking for original content they might
they might buy they might buy Netflix
that might be smart but Facebook is
doing it it's just like the youtubes the
end-all-be-all
guys we're in the this is the best time
to create if we create if your comic has
been doing the same act for 20 years
you're gonna die you're dead this is
that done you're done but you like this
[ __ ] if you like writing and you like
this world and you're like talking and
creating it's ours like I don't make
anything for a network anymore
everything I do is for my channel and
I'm sure you have offers sometimes yeah
I got offers for like I get offers for
different things it doesn't matter
people like if my boy has a special
coming out I'll be like I'll help you
curate an idea for the special that will
make that hit like even like for you
like I'm already thinking and I don't
want any money from this I just want
your your thing as you see it I'll just
be like let's think of an idea where we
can promote this in a really like even
that promo the is so goofy but it
addresses everything and it's endearing
to you yeah right it's like it shows
you're aware yep and now that person
who's gonna hate amuse like all right
that [ __ ] said everything I was
gonna say I might as well watch it yeah
yeah yeah man [ __ ] amazing
good [ __ ] happening guys I'm telling you
we're in a good place YouTube TV let's
go I'm glad I brought him there
so bad six months ago
dude you're good like let's let's talk
when yours comes out let's talk man
alright I bet we can get 15 minutes of
it to give away good camo we can and I'm
just just sell it to see so hey you know
[Laughter]
okay see so you guys trip get off C so
the C C so you are we're doing Reed's
right for your shows like with brilliant
idiots and you YouTube YouTube channel
is it all in one place or did you own
all of it or oddly brilliant you really
share but I go that's you you loud
speakers network it's not loudspeakers
network but like we each own the the
show does that make sense yes he's more
of like the guy who gets the the ads for
it yeah and he is a piece of the show
he's a piece of show and he reduces it
and like we do it produced he produces
ads for the show that that's his role
he's a great guy and he's not a greedy
guy shot - Chris morale he's do not
agree and I wish she was more greedy
yeah you know me but for you know
flagrant and these types of things it's
like these are properties and I put them
on the YouTube channel like I got to get
you guys on this this show like
basically what I realized is this I had
this like kind of awake in a moment
have you guys heard of how Nescafe
entered like the Japanese market no this
is what did
Nescafe is like this coffee stuff shout
outs a black rail coffee or whatever
black rifle
dude tired a crazy story about Clooney
man looks here this I heard that whole
Nespresso thing yeah he he he made that
just to launch a satellite that could
look after the Sudanese army so that
they could like make people aware that
the army was traveling and that's
amazing cuz he's been involved he was
involved in Darfur and all that well
really what a great guy he so he raises
he makes a special branding atrocities
on yeah so yeah hundred million dollars
like how much is the satellite 400
million ok bit let me do this coffee
company if it's true I don't know if
it's true well he made it off that and
then the tequila's well he listen you
heard about the tequila yeah I'm his boy
kept going down to Mexico they're like
this [ __ ] is great when you bring it
back and they try bring too much back
like Guinea attack she can't bring this
much back she was like wait we just need
you our own [ __ ] this is amazing and
they [ __ ] do it but we got bought up
for like us amigos was that into what
it's called is that it matter he's
killing it though but the so the Nescafe
thing right
and this shifted the way I start
thinking about content just think about
everything it's like they want to get
into the Japanese market so they're
asked this guy I forget his [ __ ] name
dr. Rob here some like that he's like
this consultant to the Stars I consulted
everybody on everything he's a [ __ ]
genius he's like codified all the
cultures right and found out what like
what moves them how they operate every
culture pretty much in the world major
one and they go we want to get into
Japan and he goes I looked at it you
can't be in there for 15 years he goes
why not he goes well because they don't
know the [ __ ] coffee is right you're
trying to be tea you're not tea they
have no idea about coffee they don't
feel coffee it means nothing to them
right it just means nothing so here's
what you're gonna do you're gonna spend
a few million dollars to make a cartoon
right and then you're gonna make some
candies based on that cartoon and those
candies are gonna taste like coffee
coffee and 15 years from now when you
enter that market they're gonna have
that call home what a weird smart guy
he's he's he's a [ __ ] super Jew is
this a doctor or something rappy
but go to Japan right now I'm sure you
guys have been all the coffee is that
I've never been saving engine it's all
say fetish it is it matter what I need a
day they will take day day listen you
have a menu
they have cones they have furnaces it
they look like chemists yes they look
like chemists you can oil over they wait
15 minutes for your [ __ ] coffee but
me serve to you in a specific cup that
has probably been thrown in the
background what when will you happily I
have everything to the end [ __ ] you
right now right now this call I think
funnel coffee yeah on Santa Monica owned
by Japanese SP yeah tape there in lab
coats man they don't do anything
half-assed do they [ __ ] off you see that
rare coffee and tea so it's a it's a
it's a science lab yes good there you
know it's a science lab beakers and [ __ ]
oh I've been there with Tony yeah it's
so serious wrong coffee yeah so smells
like a good the Japanese have they live
for artisanship and master on it yeah
your honor you understand the code yes
what is a so what did he break it down
to the Japanese code it's patience and
then impulsivity and if you look at
anything about them it's wait 15 minutes
for your coffee
yeah and then that first sip is so in
John's ice cream culture bonsai even
Catholics ok go there's there is when
you buy a cantaloupe in Japan you will
spend you can spend $50 ladies and
gentlemen for one why well because the
way they grow the cantaloupe yeah is
they they kill all the other cantaloupe
so all the all the energy goes into one
cantaloupe it's a different Kobe boy
that's right there hey Bawa GU are they
the same ones that do uh they feet is it
cat droppings or monkey droppings when
they roast no it's it's eaten by the cat
by the a but is that is that the
Japanese Indonesia it's an Indonesian
animal real quick then we can add this
if it's iPhone Madeline if I said is
that [ __ ] ship that would be is that
would the egg if I went to the Japs make
the copy like that probably don't know
more of a um so I I was in if I said oh
the Japs if they feed the monkey the
coffee the reason gaps is offensive to
Japanese is claw because rush okay well
because it did reason Japs when you say
Jazz's in World War two the GI s--
called them Japs right I'm a well if I
call them jabs the same st. Jude right
now Jewish June they're like short to
you okay Japanese [ __ ] yeah no I don't
know you go ahead and call on that I'm
gonna call the Japanese Lobby
I don't think they were the one group is
it written or do you think it's racist
cat if your friend can my damn that's a
finance jab well I hadn't eaten Koreans
don't like Japanese so they'd be fine
well no I'm just saying let's say you
were close with the Japanese person you
brought your friend over I was like that
[ __ ] is hot as [ __ ] I think it depends on
whether you're a Japanese person from
Japan or Japanese American if you're a
Japanese American you've probably been
here for generations to which that
probably doesn't have much of a negative
context as it does we would or what feel
weird saying yeah like I don't feel any
type of way if somebody says Charlie to
me they call you Charlie yeah that used
to call Vietnamese people Charlie's
that is offensive why is that offensive
because that's what you April she's not
offended
no why do you say that to fitna means
person whether it's cat or not anybody
who remembers Vietnam charlie instead of
cat personally to me I wouldn't think of
anything cuz I've won never been called
to Charlie I didn't know that until
maybe like I was in high school it was
more like [ __ ]
like that's why a lot of Vietnamese
people don't even named their kids
Charles or Charlie know that exactly
because Charlie was used as you got to
kill charlie
okay Charlie was Vietcong yeah Charlie
was in the jungle and Charlie was
someone you were killing yes are
violence attacks at work and we were
there my uncle's name Charlie yeah
Charlie as Charlie would never use for a
Vietnamese person yeah and [ __ ] is also a
little boy line right I feel weird
saying it but I better finance friend
like dammit
No so listen Americans don't care about
this [ __ ] like I did two American agents
do but like asian asian is your
Pakistani yeah so if you're shooting in
a whole lap off the last couple letters
of Villach I took a [ __ ] in the ground
that's more offensive I was like a
ground turd remember in Arab cities
where where he's singing for the first
time you say Patti and [ __ ] yeah hackie
was in the city no still you if you were
Pakistani a skinhead or a racist at Brit
usually they were gonna beat the [ __ ]
out of you because you were Pakistani
you are Indian you are Afghani then it
whatever you were that didn't matter you
were called a [ __ ] [ __ ] just meant I
don't like you [ __ ] and I'm
gonna punch you in the face so that is
jab position that though you know I'm
saying Japanese time black dudes coming
through yo what's up white boy
okay that's don't see a little bit of
weight or what's up crap world during
World War two when there are Japanese
people who are citizens of this country
and they were interned in camps
1942-1945 yeah well actually in 1942
nineteen 1939-1940 blocks probably after
41 we took them to put them in intern
camps okay yeah when you called they
were Japs call them Japs I'm just saying
that those memories they okay I'm with
you it's a there are two groups you can
get away with making fun of probably
like this Japanese people I think you
wouldn't get in trouble and Eskimos
those are the two groups that you're
probably oh you can make fun of white
people
yeah White's Inuits Japanese you could
probably cut a white some Jews I feel
like because Jews are killing us yeah
hey coach juice are you kidding
anti-semitism is at an all-time high in
my awfulness yeah bat-signal anything
any time anti-semitic like you just said
that and there was somebody in Israel to
just hurt it listen Isis know out what
I'm saying is you can't say racist
things towards Jews or stuff but i'm
saying there's a group of people who
have succeeded and came through where
you you can poke fun at certain things
if you're Jewish
Tuesday exception Tet I think okay but
like Indians and Asians like you know
you could they're not gonna back oh
you've heard my feeling is like you're
the doctor
actually they like you about five years
ago yeah maybe for and and I and I and I
was talking I was but I was being an
Indian I was doing my I was saying I was
making so I was doing I lived there so I
and that we have I grew up with a lot of
them because we probably a taxi driver
so I was no I was probably doing
something that was um not that I was
doing I was pretending to be sexy I
think I was you are so beautiful you
know my heart is it makes me crazy
yeah and it's not a sexy accent yeah
well I got about 50 emails and people
just saying very politely hey dude just
be aware that there are a lot of Indian
listeners and you can sometimes and all
the Roger you're never done says that if
you're is a curiosity Indians are
feeling Indians those Italian listeners
yeah have they ever listened to them
talk your spot I know actually things
should be celebrated and I I agree
here's the thing about it mr. P here
thing about being Indian you never favor
let's call it Hari Kondabolu
but for this is feeling their power
India you have to understand if you're
an Indian person yes if you come from
that massive continent okay they they
were a continent that hadn't colonized
by the British Empire so so by the Bible
at the end of the day what I'm trying to
say is that her accent was that funny
that Harvard you were at Polk I know
that Harvard he was widespread and they
were quote-unquote a third-world country
now become a nuclear power they have
become a Tech Center you see a lot of
Indians when they kind of my show
jacked notes in shape sexy it's it's a
different thing now so there's a there's
an Indian tribe to than Indian threat
and you know but there's an Indian fried
how would that if I'm in Canada or in
places like that how does a few for sure
but they do what you did isn't
derogatory you're not poking fun at them
see the humor in their own culture and I
don't think force I think we are living
in a weird time now where like we're
just picking and choosing what is
offensive like for example an Asian
accent maybe now is offensive if you do
a Spanish accent that's not offensive
these are both accents and we're
mimicking the sound of people but when
did asian become how you describe
somebody who has let's be honest
different eyes right now in there are 48
countries in asia but but you know asian
so I guess Vietnamese and Koreans are
the same we'll just lumping like you
guys would describe us as having
different kind of eyes
no no worse yeah you guys get that you
guys but in Asia it's common to get the
surgery to get a surgery yeah they do
surgery to you fix that yeah that's
appropriation and and they should
there's there's nothing if you do a
Asian accent it's not that's how they
sound that's how you're imitating the
way they sound yeah the same as when a
black guy imitates a white dude no wipe
him like what the [ __ ] yeah when every
black guy goes well gee Billy here you
know you're like oh that's how we sound
you're see enter this dragon right
and I was such fast 14 years old and
this is in nineteen oh you saw the first
one I did made it really at my school he
played it at my school and remember I
was 14 first time the United States had
lived over I grew up all over the world
okay so here I am as an American in
boarding school first time and I love
Bruce Lee and I was around American kids
watching a movie at my boarding school
yeah and they had it on this big screen
and my was with my buddy Darrell who was
black and he was from the Bronx could I
guess and we're sitting there and they
there's a line where Bruce Lee goes he
just don't forget y'all family or
whatever and he said I will oh man I
will oh man I will oh man and the whole
[ __ ] place and I'm like this and I go
I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] and my buddy my
buddy Darrell it was ours he goes that's
kind of racist oh it was fourteen years
I was 1981 [ __ ] old school
denied laughing white baby yeah how long
do we have before whatever how much
longer
whatever we do current events with you
yeah whatever you want to take a piss
yeah I think I got a 1:30 I gotta take a
Prius [ __ ] good man man my boy had
this [ __ ] joke that I just thought I
gotta sit on this tag but like here's
this thing about how like turtles you
know with the the plastic straws like
how the plastic straw thing is oh yeah
hey Jim you know what he goes it's he
was this fake you know what do you mean
his fake he's like he cuz he goes you're
telling me a turtle could be swimming
and then a straw is coming at him so
fast in the wreck that it lodges in its
[ __ ] nose is that what you want me to
believe so so the tag of want to give
her is like no PETA that's Peters
Jesse's milette like their stage
it's a little doses right Hardison they
do eat the plastic bag so they think
they're jellyfish
ah turns out with the straw yes elastic
bags here and also they live to 200
that's probably try to kill themselves
like if they live too long this is a
long ride only I mean that slow but that
long people become back as an arctic
shark we're gonna live 500 years in this
cold weather and you're just gonna swim
around looking I really believe they've
never seen - yeah I really believe
Stalin and Hitler and Pol Pot and all
those colors sharks I'm serious
so if you kill them it's how do you live
500 years they did carbon dating on the
inside of the eye you having lived for
hundred [ __ ] years
what yeah you're you're a ghost you're a
true ghost yeah you're blind in ice
water looking around from what you know
friends there you go what we doing so
this past weekend Pete Davidson kicked
out a heckler for making a remark about
Mac Miller oh wow where was this at New
York yep in New York he started out a
joke saying that um he had a friend who
died in his apartment to witness the
heckler screamed ow Mac Miller Oh helmet
he stopped the show had everyone point
point out the guy who said it returned
his money and kicked him out I don't
return the money yeah I would I got
whole tables
anybody who's in the table that's
enabling it to the whole table has to go
you go yeah you guys are out
I give strict if soccer everybody
stopped the whole show I don't go back
and forth whole show so I did the most
insulting thing someone can do to a
comic as long as it's just an
entertainment so it's stupid these
people that does talk and I don't know
hot chicks groups of hot chicks in my
front row like bachelor parties all they
do is talk smart yeah they talk to each
other the hotter the more self-involved
I can't date they're not even listening
they're just like
after the show yeah that's Brian's way
of explaining why there's no hot chicks
at issue we're looking at the line as I
pull it up and I think Will Sasso goes
no guys how no white guys [ __ ] white
you to all who look the same of my
bearnaise boys like the Canadian guys
wouldn't their girlfriends in tow going
who is he
yeah Dave said made sure the heckler got
his money back he's too nice got ariana
grande got some bodies on her boy what
do you like Mac [ __ ] Pete almost took
himself out like those of us something
stumped this up with hate maybe she just
lays it down so goddamn good one such a
beast I think she likes these types of
dudes I think she likes drawn to that
darkness they all kind of have that same
view there you go they have the same
vibe who did she date oh no she you know
she was with a big big big shot good
shot
yeah who has the biggest thing that's
where Big Sean comes from oh no he does
it that's Big Sean comes from his giant
dick he's a small dude
yeah but that's like comparatively
that's that Chris Rock joke like no
background of small yeah I know they say
he has just a [ __ ] pipe yeah but
compared to his leg like his deck on you
you think it'd still be big that's the
word that's the room it's like Stevie
blue eyes Stevie's got a [ __ ] piece
on him he's schooi
Stevie's money of ours open for my
reference doesn't work cuz he's got a
piece on him he got a good piece of
dwarf yeah but Big Shot Big Sean got rid
of her he's I keep too dark [ __ ] maybe
she's drawn to that negativity I don't
know maybe he started having suicidal
thoughts he's like I gotta get the [ __ ]
out dark cloud seems like an angel do it
what else you got
so 86 tons of frozen food from Boston
Market has been recalled because there's
plastic and glass inside of it that's
the least of your worries you know
frozen dinners from specifically the
boneless ribs the boneless ribs have
plastic and glass in them yeah no [ __ ]
McDonald goes hold my beer yeah you ever
seen the [ __ ] McRib
it's a [ __ ] sponge change - you
bought a McRib I bought another Boston
freaking market frozen entree last night
and then she saw no chance but I do
sometimes lazy I don't cook yes Margo
good for you don't be bullied stick a
plastic frozen kill a turtle gin you get
happy it is on as a kid I used to eat
them do you get happy we get to the
[ __ ] like the cinnamon apples or some
[ __ ] I don't buy those anymore but he
was happy about those before that's the
Southbridge take a little treat treat
yeah what else you got alright okay so a
YouTube video got flagged because it was
promoted on YouTube kids we're four
minutes in a cartoon character would
give you instructions on how to cut
yourself what da [ __ ] that's a little
crazy where did this some random guy a
lot of people have been rolling this
yeah uh I don't know if it's I think
it's trolling but this has been a
phenomenon as of late because maybe like
four minutes into YouTube kids like
you're not watching what your kid
knowledge is that entire time like
almost all segments where something's
[ __ ] up damn that's I would like to
find that [ __ ] and pissing with
our daily stuff beat him with a bat do
you know I did today
this was remind me of it how you always
got to watch out for kids yeah we got
this new nanny and my girls like no
she's great short to this dude and
better this kid Beauvoir I'm like yeah
but do you know her she's like no I'm
like whoa so we're just gonna let her
watch alright Tiger right now she's like
yes she's great I'm telling you everyone
recommends her I'm like oh cool and so I
take a shot get done worked out think
you shot come down like where's Tigers
she's like oh the nanny took him to the
parking like alone she goes yeah so I
did operation Koh Samui and [ __ ]
staked out watch this [ __ ] for a solid
45 minutes for sure my mom behind the
bushes like
that's amazing yeah but it's also you
look so creepy okay I know my giant
truck just yeah that's a razor so you
can't tell the cop oh it's my kid
yeah giant guy with cauliflower hairs
yeah yeah yeah dude no that's the way to
do it my mom said she did that with me I
would have like rashes as a kid so she
would she like follow the the babysitter
and apparently the babysitter would sit
me in the swing not even pushed me she
just sent me there for hours in the
[ __ ] hours my mom said I watched her
my mom's gotcha I watched their fur she
must have let you sit there for two
hours
mom you didn't spin she's drama we're in
Scotland right outside of Glasgow koha
school oh you're good you're good we'll
see I'm still doing my investigation
I'll building up my evidence on this
[ __ ] you can't trust a man not in the
videos of those nannies like hittin the
kittens like possums yeah yeah it's
crazy you have to kill a [ __ ] yeah you
have to you don't show them I want to
kill the guy I hope they find the guy
who put that video on piece of [ __ ] I'd
like to kill him so the story went viral
a couple days ago about him buying I
think it was about 20 25 dollars worth
of Girl Scout cookies he came back later
bought 540 which was the rest that the
two girls had because he said that he
didn't want them staying in the cold
they're in North Carolina and so it went
viral he was using it to the PR to make
it seem like he was a pillar of the
community just few days later he got
arrested for drugs oh wow and police are
saying that he strategically used all of
the PR that he got from this story going
viral to make it seem like he was a
great guy to get away with selling drugs
oh wow a bad idea to draw any attention
you're a drug deal yeah yeah well
because no one buying drugs like dude
are you are you thinking about all the
[ __ ]
I'm in y'all take a grand unless he was
trying to turn around and was selling
them for a premium in a Girl Scout it
was always his fantasy to be a Girl
Scout cookies bro hey selling drugs
maybe you bought that maybe he's a good
guy he bought the board baby head and
it's all dreaming maybe add much he's
like a mother fun yeah it doesn't mean
he's a bad guy just [ __ ] strong why
do we have kids some cookies still how
old school is that I don't even trust
them my daughter does don't trust anyone
why my daughter's a Girl Scout she sells
cookies good cuz it's good for a Girl
Scouts cuz they teach you how to take
rejection my daughter I follow I had sit
walk oh wait behind her as she knocked
on every door in the neighborhood and
she could was talked about cookies and
everybody would be I swear to God
everybody in my neighborhood no thank
you
am i proud of my daughter would go you
daughters like no she go thank you with
her little clipboard and they're
launching away and I was like I was like
I'll [ __ ] kill everybody in my
[ __ ] neighborhood and then I got a
little too close to his dad stay back
you're ruining my flow and so I had to I
had to like just follow her when she
come papa shops house should they not
come I look around you yeah tag along I
take it more I couldn't believe you were
like no and some people are like they
just over to open the door the crack may
go no no trust me but my daughter was
like okay it's not your daughter it's
that it's not her punch good rejection
but in my heart breaks what I don't like
you see her daughter get rejected I
don't you do a little fan video and so
she could sell those [ __ ] it's a good
point
what one of the things that I keep
having in my thought is that she she had
AI had to be we did career day yeah and
I had the kids come up and do a line I
can't said let's see how you do this
line and my daughter finally came up and
I was daddy and some of the kids knew
the show and she had her hand like that
and and she did the line but she
actually did it better than everybody
else and I went I heard did you see how
she emphasized that and I said there are
actually the best in the class and she
goes yeah I I'm in stage class like it
was nothing yeah alright fine I got to
make sure she doesn't I don't want my
kids to be actors though well I got a
clip those wings
I'm just you know I'm to make millions
of dollars and for doing something
or or never work that's what happens but
they'll find their way yeah what else
you it worked out for you with us yet
it's steel behind you guys literally
right behind knock on his door and just
let him know Bo I think maybe just as
producers that oh really he was not
there yet I'm cuz I was supposed to do
130 with him but can we just talk [ __ ]
or not give it give us thanks steel
right now all right just text it cuz if
he's right we'll just rock it right
until then right on while you guys text
I'm just gonna throw this up real quick
Roman reigns he had leukemia if you
remember twice already
yeah so you know it's not Monday that
he's in remission that's good news
that's great yeah I'll play the clip for
you guys oh you good texture no no go
ahead I just taste the ice ah so when I
tell you this I am so grateful I'm so
humbled and I'm so honored to announce
this I'm trans would that be a great
walking walk before we can run but the
good news is I'm in remission y'all it's
got to feel good
what kind of leukemia this yeah I'm not
sure with the type
don't feel it's essentially come knock
on and with this producer with ya but
you hit them up right yeah alright that
that's good man good news
speaking of transgender though you said
transgender right sure this person here
this gentleman Nick Nicky jolly maja
who's a gay rights activist it's kind of
similar to the jessie Smollett thing
oh yeah fake the house 5 yeah he burned
his own house or faked house fire and
his own dogs and he's his eyes on point
[ __ ] what are they called
the little ones branching into a woman
for him it's almost like okay that's a
tough song yeah it's a tough stuff if
you're a lady a woman who decided that
he wants yeah I'm confused but anyway he
looks like one of those things making
coffee and men in black there's some
stuff going on there dude we're gonna
like we're gonna release him right now
we've been knockin bro we've been
knocking you just got oh you know
podcast come here what is this what does
this person look like okay ready - here
we go
I mean what would different air yep oh
it's trainer man yeah that's not the
issue let's let his house on fire he
said a woman or wasn't
now it's a nanny jollies
oh so was a woman now man Oh soso went
from woman to man yes he got you okay
well he he lit his house on fire to to
basically pretend it was a hate crime
neither did his dogs and cats get hurt
yes to is or to how many birds does she
have so three cats and two dogs she
killed her or he killed all the animals
like no his dark brother should have
said yeah and they're saying he was
trying to do like a gay pride thing
festival or whatever and it wasn't like
the turnout wasn't that great wasn't
popping so that's why he did this yeah
yeah so it's very similar to this mullet
yeah that's a problem
it just looks so weird yeah it's strange
looking person yeah the left eye is just
far set back I think I think Brian knows
who's blondie you guys don't know he's a
lazy eye he's Forest Whitaker are they
sure or is an old sniper killer did they
test this person for Forest Whitaker
strange from Jessie Smollett huh yes
lost some UFC let's see the let's see my
lat well the only update that I saw if I
could Freddie well that was one of it
they deleted or they they stopped to the
last episodes that featured him so they
kicked him off of that
yeah then one of the brothers else and
area brothers those big blocking
Nigerians yeah we found an old tweet
that showed that it was like some sort
of small homophobic remark they're gonna
use that guy that the defense for sure
he's fun he's actually claiming his
until what would you so you you you know
that the the sort of Twitter spear out
there idea or if you're Jessie smell it
you your personal you're an [ __ ] and
your duck or what do you do well I would
come out of straight
yeah yeah yeah like I'm straight oh come
out straight everybody I believe is on a
hole why dude he's gonna be in Hamilton
next year we know it I would say this if
I'm just Malay I go look I hired black
guys I kept it in the community
yep I think that I kept in the community
no no like I look at all these guys out
here that aren't supporting black
business etc and he's like I care about
my people at least I hired these guys to
support so there's a good idea
the defense will use this as ethics oh
so smug because even the the the black
culture isn't supporting them they're
like now you're full of [ __ ] can a
couple guys are I think they said who is
Tracy McGrady I think and one other
transparent Howard no he's like yeah
yeah but also a small it a mean that
black look at him his sister can get it
though she's like she wants journey yeah
yeah time is shitty man oh look at his
sister that turret Ellen Page oh she had
something to say about that Ellen Page
darkus Ellen Page is really oh wow the
DSL L ELLs we'd have seen if she's an
actress huh yeah I can't remem Artin I
think pretty in there any others too
what's more you good out of here hey
check out my special oh yeah even
advertise the guy special the guy comes
from New York do you see one guy he's
from the SIS views from the SIS yeah
from as in Mississippi or male right
yeah
have you seen someone's me too but come
check it out yeah check it out
youtube.com slash the end result I broke
it up in those six parts and I had new
one drops every Sunday and I can't get
it weird
you too youtube.com slash DeAndre
Scholes yeah go check it out man I think
this work I don't know when this coming
out but I am live
you ever seen in life no never real life
never live I've seen all this mutant
life now and your imagination what is
good or not you do the Comedy Store I'm
sure it's good yeah do a couple shows
tomorrow there I got a couple show
that's why I'm in town dude he outside
no yeah yeah yeah yeah Beast easy good
break easy
I'm have you seen a Little Red Riding
Hood that book where they have that wolf
yeah that's him really yeah Andrew show
thanks for joining
appreciate y'all man
wish I'd met you before fantastic guy
yes can I help but the like that guy I
told you man I told you and he knows
comedy that zero ground yeah easy might
be six three he says yes all right kiddo
smart dude and with the same age that
shouldn't call me kid but well I wish I
wish I had known what he knows I know
right I shoulda listened to you
month doesn't matter where you gonna
bait man Miami
March 15th through the 16th Miami improv
after that man Milwaukee
that's the paps theater that's March
22nd through the 23rd after that I'm in
DC March 28th through the 30th back on
the road the BD D on horse starts in
March dear can you pack a calm for
tickets B we going Salt Lake City this
weekend March 1st and 2nd Friday
Saturday this Friday Saturday come see
me tickets are almost gone and then can
then I got March 14th at Cobbs for the
make-a-wish Foundation come by one night
only at Cobbs comedy club in San
Francisco
Kansas City improv March 22nd and 23rd
and then Philadelphia helium March 28th
29th and 30th I can't wait this is this
is the finally kid we're out